well today the Salvation Army treating  around 200 families to a Thanksgiving  meal families drove through and picked  up a box with a turkey and sides  Salvation Army County coordinator  Anthony Barnes says it's important to  help those in need this time of the year  it makes us feel wonderful to know that  we can partner with these families walk  alongside and do life with them make  sure that they have at the very least  their most basic needs met and if they  can put a turkey on the table with some  stuffing and some mashed potatoes and  gravy and enjoy the holiday season  without any worry of where that's going  to come from this year we're happy to  provide that all right if you want to  volunteer we have links to the Salvation  Army on our website 8newsnow.com